So what are some of the challenges
when it comes to the CFAA or the DMCA?
The laws that we just talked
about related to fraud abuse and
protection of distal objects.
First of all, enforcement is
actually quite challenging.
It's difficult for a number of reason
first of all, attribution is hard.
How exactly do you know that this is
the person who was responsible for
something fraudulent that was done?
We know that a request or data may
have flowed to a certain computer,
but there may be malware
sitting on that computer.
It may not be any fault of the person
who owns that computer, it could be some
bot that's under the control of somebody
else who's actually doing that.
So how exactly do you attribute
a certain illegal activity,
or action to a person?
And what makes this really even harder
is the fact that the internet
has no national boundaries.
So that international nature or the
transnational nature of the internet,
of course presents another
set of challenges.
Finally, I think we had
a quiz question talking about
have the various laws related
to computer fraud done any good?
Have they reduced cyber crime or
has cyber crime gone up?
Well one of the challenges that we,
making laws is a slow process.
And cyber criminals can
basically stay ahead of it.
The criminal ecosystem
can keep evolving.
They can work around the legal
safeguards we put in place.
Though and that can happen very rapidly,
much faster than our ability
to put laws in place and
find ways to enforce them,
get people in front of judges and
courts and things like that.
So there have been cases
we're going to look at a few,
but obviously one of the challenges.
How do you stay current with what is
going on in the cyber criminal world?